John Buffalo mayor of an actor a writer
and producer and journalist
it was a it was a fairly extensive
rehearsal process took trips out to Long
Island and kind of just got to the the
feel of the town that we had said my
character coming from voice lessons
learning the floor learning the the
actual trade of Wall Street traders is
in kind of incredible process so Shia
myself several of the people we just
spent as many hours as we could
shadowing different traders on the floor
kind of funding where it stands today
how it's different from the first Wall
Street how it's the same it was a it was
an amazing ride I'll tell you that
well the numbers are bigger for one
thing it's a much more global it's less
centric to whatever area you're in you
know some floors you go in and when the
bell rings it's silent and all you see
are the computer screen starting to
light up as people do different trades
it used to be a kind of big bag would
start off the day I a company that was
was I think the one I learned the most
probably just in terms of my own
character and the kind of firm he worked
there and was John Thomas financial and
there it's like you know warriors and an
arena getting ready for battle
Tommy police is just fires these guys up
like there's no tomorrow and I
absolutely got addicted to that optimism
and adrenaline and what can I do it what
can I do it buddy kind of attitude that
he had so I you know it runs the full
spectrum his firm is much more like what
it used to be in terms of warriors on a
mission I think now it's a lot more
relaxed you see a lot of sneakers and
jeans and places depending on which firm
you're talking to
I had a lot of preconceived notions
going in it wasn't an industry that I
really respected much my feeling was
kind of like looking you're not making
anything you're taking money from one
place putting it in another and taking a
cut and that's just not really kind of
soul satisfying at the end of the day
but what I learned is on a larger scale
is how much the Wall Street industry
funnels and fuels so many others and we
would not have a lot of medical research
without it we would not have you know
educational programs with that if
there's a little good that these guys do
and to lump all traders into a
categories as insane as something any
group of people into one category you're
going to find good people in bed and all
around I had a lot of fun with those
guys that laughter is unlike most
settings you'll find the level of
intensity the adrenaline the stakes are
incredible I mean it is addictive I can
understand why people end up spending 23
or 24 hours a day hidden it
not at all not at all I mean I think one
of the larger problems going on right
now is debate has replaced discussion I
as I say you can't lump Wall Street into
one category that doesn't mean anything
every firm has a different attitude and
does different things and puts their
cherries in certain places and their
money and others some are vicious nasty
I will cut you down at all costs to make
a buck
some have a much higher moral standard I
Eve my hope is that the film will
actually serve as a way for us to bridge
that gap between Wall Street and Main
Street certainly that's dealt with in
the film of how it does affect everybody
so you know I always find that when you
can create a movie or a play or a book
that that gives somebody a safe
theoretical place to discuss what's
really going on the day it tends to
forward discussion so that would be my
hope coming out of the film
you know I grew up in an artistic family
where everyone was doing something in
one field of the arts or another I was I
think 12 years old when I did my first
acting at the Actors Studio and it's you
know James Dean once said that the only
reason to become an actor is because you
have to I think that you know from a
young age if that is a certain rush that
you're going to need to satisfy you and
to make you feel fulfilled and if you
don't then you shouldn't do it there's
jus it's just too brutal of a business
most of the time so I think that at the
ripe old age of 12 have figured out you
know I kind of like I kind of like this
thing I like talking to these people
man it's apples and oranges you can't
really beat movies it's a fun gig I mean
it's nice to it's nice to have a trailer
and makeup and you know an entire army
that's basically all there for the same
purpose which is make the best film we
can yeah when you're on an Oliver Stone
said everybody brings their a game
everybody brings their a game from the
top to the bottom and in between in
terms of theater you know there's no
there's no way to really duplicate that
rush you get when you take an audience
that is live and right there in front of
you through the journey of a great play
and you go through these emotions so
that they can experience them without
having to go through them themselves
it's a certain kind of human compact
that obviously you lose as soon as
there's a screen and a camera there so I
think yeah I think we'll always have
theater I think theater will always be a
powerful force because we need that
human touch particularly as we spend
more and more time with machines with
cell phones computers we start to lose
our humanity I mean the the price of our
technology may very well end up being
our humanity so I think you got to have
that balance personally I try to do one
for one if I can do a movie do a play do
a movie to a play well at the same time
writing and being in that cycle those
two fields are very writing and acting
or almost diametrically opposed in terms
of being an actor it's in your interest
to be in shape and to be healthy and to
have a strong voice and to be flexible
as a writer you're sitting in this
position for hours on end you get up and
you can put your shoulder down it's it's
not a healthy existence so to speak and
it's probably not healthy for the person
who lives with you either but um you do
the best you can
you know I'm probably most proud of the
place that I've written just because as
the playwright you know you're God you
get to do everything you don't make any
money hardly at all but you you really
get to kind of control the scene as a
screenwriter you're the towel boy in the
whorehouse I mean you you know you're
lucky if you're invited to said it's Kay
it's kind of like here's the blueprint
go and that's you know there's been some
debate as to whether or not a film
should be by the director or by the
screenwriter or by both screw writer
lost out on that directors win and in
theater it's absolutely the opposite but
you know um I'm proud of all the well of
most of the theater acting that I've
done the thing is to try to talk about a
performance that will never be seen
again
that was only lived by the people there
it's kind of like telling somebody about
your dream you know they'll though if
they love you they'll listen and smile
but they can't really get it so there is
a certain infinite quality to to film
that is nice you do the work and you
know it's always going to be there
I you know I just I love telling stories
and as long as I can make my living
doing that in in all the different
mediums that I have been lucky enough to
that's enough for me really it's a you
know there's different scales of stories
sometimes you want to tell one that 20
30 40 50 million people will want to see
and hear sometimes you do one that you
know 150 you'll want to see on one night
I as long as you're telling the right
story for the right audience and they're
getting something out of it it's
essentially the same feeling to me
obviously there's you know the economic
necessity of paying your bills and how
do you do that 10 years ago when I
started out I was kind of told I was
insane for trying to pursue multiple
fields at once because in five years
everyone who just did one would have
five times the resume I would if I was
lucky but I took that gamble cuz I just
my gut told me was the right thing to do
and you know as an actor there's so much
downtown you want to fill it with
something else and there's a writer you
know sometimes you're doing a passion
project sometimes it's a paid gig
sometimes there's nothing so you can do
a journalistic piece at this point I
think the shift start in about 2008 a
lot of factors while I'm sure but
whatever the reasons 2008 it felt as
though the the combination of
distribution models starting to tighten
and the publishing and film and music
industries having to revolutionize
themselves to catch up and understand
how this is going to work in the new
millennium
has made it a lot easier to pursue
multi-platform careers it's much easier
to hire one person who can do three or
four different things than one
specialist in that field which as I
think about the college graduating
classes and high school classes that are
coming up now they're in a unique
position I mean they're entering one of
the toughest economies of all time at
the same time if they're willing to work
really hard the ability they have to
learn something much faster than we ever
did before is there and it's really a
question of are you willing to put in
the effort and go that extra marks if
you are I think there's actually more
opportunities out there
there's an interesting question of what
was it like to grow up as Norman
Mailer's son because I could easily turn
it back and say what was it like not to
I don't really have a comparison aside
from friends of mine and discussions but
I think I do have a gauge of some of the
differences that it would be because I
didn't always realize my dad was Norman
Mailer I always said he was dead and
then I forget the exact age when it
dawned on me that you know he's actually
someone who affects the public
consciousness at the time it was amazing
I mean he was a rock star and brilliant
and kind and funny and generous and
scary when he needed to be and you know
hard as a father I mean he expected a
lot from us and he really pushed us and
you know one of his favorite lines was
if you think I'm being hard on your way
to life it's you because life is a hell
of a lot tougher than I am and I took
everything he said to heart I mean he
taught me how to ride which was scary
and intimidating and hard but ultimately
one of the biggest gifts I could have
ever asked for
there's one moment that actually comes
to mind when you think of the kind of
crystallizing factor you know I kind of
lived a utopian existence until I was
about twenty twenty-one when my mom got
sick with cancer and it was it was bad
it was very scary and at the time I was
doing my first screenplay and was on
deadline and was alone with my father in
Massachusetts she was recovering in the
hospital we were going back and forth
and she wasn't gonna be able to come
home for a few days but we knew about
the longer road ahead and the chemo and
the radiation and all that and at
certain points if my dad said pop you
know I yeah I don't know how I'm gonna
work I don't know how I can get this
done you know I got a hand this script
in and I can't think about anything but
mommy said well you know now is the time
when you go learn what it means to
compartmentalize and those words really
had an impact on me and have enabled me
through the last ten years of more
surgeries than I care to remember and
more scary time
and I wish my mother had ever had to go
through those words enabled me to
actually continue to do my job and to
get my work done which is so important
if you have meant for all those who have
kind of helped someone heal through a
sickness you know it's just so important
to be able to bring exciting news to the
table and to be able to get them get
their minds off of the fact that they're
sick and to do that you got to you got
to work your ass off and have some
successes and bring in some things so
those words I mean you know I could pick
a million different instances with with
my dad but that one moment when he you
know he didn't say I understand go you
know lay down and cry go do this he said
no be a man stand up compartmentalize
get your work done and that's and that's
really what it means to be a man is to
take on all the emotional pain and to
work through what you got to work
through with the people you love well at
the same time getting your business done
and it's tough and I think that most
children when they grow up they kind of
realized that the things they didn't
like about their parents who didn't
understand about them they get now and
that you know every year you get more
responsibilities get more overhead you
get more things we got to take care of
it's hard to keep a chip or open happy
attitude about all the time and and you
shouldn't because part of part of it is
preparing your kids for when they're
gonna take over the rights I'm gonna do
it so I was just incredibly thankful for
that particular moment
oh wow well he probably told me
everything I know
excite from dialogue which I think I get
from my mom a lot more he certainly
didn't teach me everything he knew but
uh you know he's got this book out
called the spooky art which is
essentially an advanced book on writing
that's not you know it's not Navy Seas
but it's for people who feel that bug
and know that their writers and are
willing to put in that time alone pretty
much
the vast majority what he taught me you
can find in that book uh you know some
basic things of don't say something
twice find the right way to say it don't
use words you don't need don't use
adjectives to describe something there's
some basic stuff in there the nuance of
a character and the journey and what it
means to write a novel you know these
are deep philosophical conversations
that you can't really put a button on
work ethic is one of the biggest things
he told me that man worked like every
day every day 9:00 to 5:00 well not a
nod in his case but he would treat as if
it was a nine-to-five job he would clock
in he would put in his hours that's how
you can write those you know incredibly
long books that unfortunately there's
not much market for anymore but that's
also how you can explore an idea on a
deeper level than we get and are in our
media surface these days it's uh it's
tough I mean just not a little side note
with that one of the reasons I'm so
happy to be doing the show is because
one of the virtues of the Internet is
that now for those who want it you can
get into something that is deeper than
what you have in 35 seconds or a minute
on whichever pundits show you're doing
which are essentially designed to
reinforce what people already think and
not make them question anything Noam
Chomsky is is in some ways a a victim of
this this new millennium we live in
because you can't pull a soundbite from
that guy and understand what he's
talking about you have to hear the whole
paragraph you have to hear the whole
page you're gonna hear the whole
conversation if you really want to
understand it and that could change your
life but it's almost as though we've
been duped into believing we don't have
25 minutes to have something change our
life we don't have to you know we're
tweeting we're running around with 15
words or less
you know that to me I don't think
there's any conspiracy or master plan
behind it but it does echo 1984 and you
combine that with you know the amount of
medications that doctors are prescribing
for people and suddenly were in brave
new world and it's this bizarre
combination of events that I don't think
was plaid I don't think there's any kind
of plot on anyone's part it's just that
our system is gearing us this way and we
need to address that we need to address
that publicly in a way that is
productive in a way that actually gives
people tangible things they can do to
stop the insanity of being available
every moment things like that
oh my god I mean if anything his problem
was that he didn't realize that humor
will not translate in sound bytes in
quotes and so oftentimes he would say
something you know just off the cuff
that was silly and funny and ridiculous
and everyone there would laugh like he
wouldn't believe and then it would end
up in print the next day and you know
something crazy like Norman Mailer said
women should be kept in cages you know
things things like that it was just he
loved women so much I mean probably more
than anything in the world he loved
women he got put into a position where
he was kind of seen as the the
anti-feminist although he was he was for
the feminist movement he just didn't
want people to get consumed with the
idea that this was going to be much
better he said look women should be
treated equally and fairly there's no
question about it but there was a
certain kind totalitarian element I
think when the movement was starting off
with so many different factions and
that's I think what he was taking issue
with was the idea of look II can't go
from male dominance to female dominance
and expect anything to be better we're
all were all shits ultimately we got to
do the best we can together um so I you
know and those of those who were lucky
enough to know my dad know that he was
one of the funniest guys who ever lived
I mean he had this great I thought it
was great I shouldn't shouldn't preface
it by saying it was great but he had he
had this joke used to tell whenever he
would start a lecture he always would
flip the jokes around he had what he
would do for a year or so but basically
he said that he was about karma and
reincarnation and he said you know so I
die and I go up to the gates and I see
Gabriel I says well mr. mailer was so
happy to see you within expecting you
for a while and and we asked this of all
of our new recipients what would you
like to be reincarnated as it's a
question we ask everybody because we see
that you're on the list for
reincarnation so as well you know I'd
like to be a black athlete honestly
that's you know I don't know you put
stop me in a ghetto do whatever I'll
work my way out but I would really have
been this kind of little Jewish guy all
my life and I've you know done what I've
done but that's what I really want to be
the gamer says oh well I hate to tell
you this mr. mailer but um black
athletes are the most over subscribe to
reincarnation request we have it's a
list that goes miles long I can't I
can't tell you you know the chances are
good but let me let me see we have you
down for and then we can work from there
he looks and goes well we have you down
for cockroach but you're gonna be the
fastest cockroach on the block and that
was my dad's sense of you know laughing
at himself laughing at existence the
universe all of it and not not being too
serious about what we deal with because
at the end of the day if you're here
it's a blessing it's you know life is
hard
life is hard for everybody at some point
but it's those were able to laugh at it
and and laugh with it and roll with it
that ultimately I think lived a
fulfilling lives that we're all trying
to do you know I'm big step there is to
not take yourself too seriously from the
story
there's several people out there who who
I feel are doing their part in that way
I would say the only one person I know
of who kind of combines the the elements
that my father brought to the table in
terms of effect in the public discourse
would be Oliver Stone his combination of
academic brilliance and real-life
experience and just understanding people
I think is what makes him such a great
storyteller but also he cares he's
interested he meets somebody and he he
listens him he has some questions he
wants to know what they're about and as
a result I think his worldview is much
more complex and whole and most of the
other I don't know if we can even have a
category of public intellectual anymore
but he would be in that category he
would be out there the reason one of the
things that sets him apart though is
he's commercial he's mainstream he makes
big movies and he's one of the last guys
that can make big movies that actually
have something to say that you know
challenge the audience in a way while
entertaining them but there's you know
there's the the there's a lot of people
out there who are doing it I don't know
if it's possible for anyone to really
have that that level of a voice anymore
because our media is so diluted and and
parsed out you know people kind of go
for the news and information that they
want as opposed to picking up a paper
and seeing what catches their eye it's a
very stark difference and I you know
it's it's there's a few stories that end
up going wide and everybody hears about
them but they're usually salacious
celebrity stuff that is not about
substance or it's the latest disaster
and it's kind of covered in a way that
it's just trying to get eyeballs on the
screen it's not you know I mean I think
that Anderson Cooper does a great job of
staying with stories and pushing him new
orleans he really he was there and he
and he pushed it past the point where
his producers are saying listen you got
to stop because people are tuning out
now you know we're on to another
disaster you know these days what are
you worried about Haiti Chile Turkey
what you know where do you where do you
put your attention on your focus so for
one person to really be able to cover
all that ground would be tough also I
think that yeah you have experts in
field to spend their life studying one
thing an event goes on like that
chances oh they're gonna want that
specific expert who's done it to be on
the show talking about it not a writer
or an artist of any sort which i think
is a mistake because you know we don't
have only we have them but they're
certainly not not you know in strong
force a public philosophers anymore the
only way you're going to get that kind
of metaphorical larger take on what is
actually happening and what it means to
us and what it's going to be in a few
years is to talk to people whose job it
is to take life and turn it into stories
and create it and frame it so it's it's
a tough role to fill I think that one of
the things that my dad was grappling
with towards the end was how that shift
had happened now and he would go on a
book tour and do his shows and it would
be you know fulfilling and good but he
wouldn't have the same impact that he
used to and it wasn't because people
were less interested it's just because
people are distracted by the million
different sources of entertainment and
information in front of them at any
given time
ah you know there's a lot of forces
opposed to it
so I don't want to put the cart before
the horse it's looking like it's going
the legalization route which you know a
lot of people thought it needs to for a
long time
outside of recreational and medicinal
use just for crime reasons you know
we're pumping our prisons full of petty
weed offenses and it's you know
partially to feed that industry but it's
not good it's not good for society and
you know people go in there as a minor
criminal and come out as a real criminal
you know it seems to be the sense of
once he throw guys in prison the they're
not gonna come out no they're gonna come
out and you know what kind of beasts
have you created from that process so I
you know we in 2004 when we were running
high times we took it in a very
political direction and it was like a
night and day transformation probably
too radical honestly in terms of the
timing of the business mechanics of it
but we did you know we were we had one
of the original pot smugglers turned
outlaw writer who had started the
magazine there and he was a wild man
Richard Stratton and myself and adding a
sensei and we just said hey we've got a
chance to really do what we want to do
with this magazine and the response was
great I got to say that people you know
we're tickled to be reading High Times
do you take it out on the train do
you're not things like that
but overall they were saying there's no
other national magazine that we can get
this kind of information from because
essentially High Times is a mom-and-pop
national magazine there's no corporate
structure that you have to answer to you
know it's why I think it will always be
around has been around for over 30 years
now so hopefully we played a small part
in elevating the argument about
legalization making it less hey man stay
off my weed - listen we shouldn't be
putting people in jail for this this is
a civil liberty issue you know do what
you want to your body when you're alone
so he's not hurting anyone else and
trying to take that tack on it I think
they're probably the normal organization
and Ethan Adelman are most responsible
for what's been going on but you know
having a mother who's
who's had cancer and thought through it
and at times use cannabis to you know
fight off nausea and what do I mean it's
not really her thing but there were
times when she needed it and the idea
that you can't have it because it's an
illegal drug but oxycontin is legal
that's you know that's just insane to a
level that I think most people
understand
now what's against legalization and in a
practical sense you've got the oil
industry you've got the cotton industry
you've got the paper industry you've got
alcohol and tobacco to a certain extent
all of these industries are affected
adversely by this there's a story I
don't know if it's true but it made
sense to me that a William Randolph
Hearst actually back in the 30s I guess
had just purchased a whole fields and
fields and fields of trees to print his
paper on and at the same time a couple
of college kids figured out how to take
a hemp plant and turn it into newspaper
and it was actually a better quality of
paper it was cheaper and if you plant
hands in a field it revitalizes in the
soil you can grow food in a dirt lot if
you do enough harvest of him and her
said this is gonna put me out of
business I just spent all my money on
these trees so that's why he started
that campaign linking hemp and marijuana
together calling it the devil's harvest
and all that again I you know I read
this story when I was at high times it
seemed like a legitimate source who
knows if it's true or not but it makes
sense and that's the kind of thing
you're up against I think that a the
reason why pot is illegal is much more
because of hemp than it is for any
societal reasons or stigma
absolutely there is I mean you know
listen we could be taxing it and making
a bundle off of it you know now I don't
pretend to know the specifics of the
economics of it to say how much we were
beginning but there's money to be made
there that is not being made because
it's illegal now granted there's a lot
of money that is being made because it's
illegal and those people you'd have to
contend with as well who are certainly
not for it becoming legal you know and
then there's also just socially
personally there's something naughty
about Bob there's something that is is
rebellious and outlaw and a kind of you
know a finger in the eye the
government's saying hey you can't tell
me what to do that would be gone I've
never talked to my dad about it in the
book we did together called the big
empty uh he would say like oh no no as
soon as it's legalized it'll be ruined
you know the corporation's will get
their hands on it you'll have you know
pop with vitamin C and you know viagra
ties hi toe there are different things
like that that it won't be you know
they'll put chemicals into it it won't
be that pure plant that it is now he may
have a good point there although I think
that if you look at places like
Amsterdam and places where pot is very
legal they do well with it there's
nothing taken away from it and crime is
very low and all the
I'll put it to you this way as wild as
you think it is as well as you imagine
it is it's even Wilder like it is a
crazy Willy Wonka LAN environment to be
running a magazine out of and truth be
told if what we were trying to pull off
were to work I think I was the wrong guy
for it because I was I was 25 years old
I was sent in first to kind of assess
the staff and the team and see who could
stay and who would go with the shake-up
and you know I'm a nicer guy than I
should be in a lot of instances but I
couldn't look at that
you know 55 year old advertising
director with the the long ratty gray
hair who would forget his teeth often
times coming in and like you know I said
who are you and he's like oh I'm your ad
man oh we're and I couldn't look at that
guy and know that if I fired him he was
gonna lose custody of his kid and
probably wouldn't be able to get another
job anywhere else cuz he'd been there
for so long that's not something I
wanted on my conscience not something
that I felt like doing I wasn't willing
to sacrifice that for the greater good
of the magazine if it was going to work
we should have fired everybody and
brought in six people that had the same
vision and knew what they were doing
could do it instead I tried to kind of
like get everyone behind it and it
worked half it half worked half the
people were just too paranoid and and
scared of losing their jobs and so we're
kind of you know putting on the happy
face and then the the stuff going on
behind one's pack was insane I you know
I ended up walking away from that place
with an appreciation for the education
that I've been given I mean essentially
I got paid for a year to really learn
magazine publishing from top to bottom
and in certain out and that has helped
me a lot we were also a little ahead of
our time because while we took a huge
hit on advertising we couldn't you know
there was cultural advertising we
couldn't have in with the new direction
of the magazine and didn't really have
the time or abilities to fill that in we
doubled the web traffic and dad was my
son it was kind of what I was using as
my argument to say hey give it another a
few years this is going to work because
back then they didn't really understand
what that man
they didn't really see how quickly
everything is moving to the web and how
essentially print magazines are going to
be collectors items before we know it as
each generation comes up that doesn't
have the habits for paper it's just
easier and cheaper to get your stuff
online you know people go to what
they're used to certainly our generation
you know will always won't have a
magazine in our hands we like that but
they didn't see the value in that
necessarily and you know they may have
been right before all I do because it
was another few years until really ad
revenue starts to move to the websites
so you know so at they at the end of the
day was an experiment it was something
that hopefully sparked a few people to
do similar things down the road and will
keep a certain flavor of a magazine
publishing live I have to say at the end
of the day I am glad not to be spending
all day every day in the high Times
office you know covering this this
particular angle of life
hmm what harsh is my mellow well I just
had a a movie that was set and ready to
go with amazing stars and amazing
director and amazing producer and
everyone and because of a technicality
unfortunately the whole thing just fell
apart
that horsemen mellow a little bit but
again you know the if you if you're
gonna go into the movie business it is
so full of heartbreak and you get so
close so it doesn't happen and then once
in a while it works out and it is the
fantasy like it is that dream so riding
the highs and lows of it you gotta have
an iron Constitution and you got to be
able to do what David Dinkins actually
once said who you know it was a mayor of
New York back in the early 90s late 80s
and had a rough time you know one day
after another there's something and
actually my father was talking to him he
said so you know mr. Jenkins how do you
how do you navigate it all I said well
you know some days are good some days
are bad but anytime there's a bad day I
know the next day is gonna be good and
vice versa so you just can't put too
much stock in that moment I think that
that ultimately when life is not tragedy
it should be a party and if you've if
you face the real stuff you face the
ones closest to you being a desk door
passing on you know not to let this
small stuff really harshmellow
as you put it
you